ristin is with us in atlanta hi Wriston
how are you hi good good how can I help
my question is we have racked up over
twenty thousand dollars in credit card
debt in the past two years and we also
owe a family member ten thousand dollars
we've never struggled for money we've
always been able to pay a credit card
off we've had a couple life changes the
moves and job changes we are able to pay
off our home mortgage still we are able
to pay off our car loans but we cannot
get this credit card down we cannot have
money to pay this family member off and
what do we do
what's your household income my husband
makes about a hundred thousand and I
just started going back to work after
raising kids for 12 years I make ten
dollars an hour and a little art studio
not very much are you working for tea no
I only work part-time okay and and how
much do you owe on your cars we owe
about $40,000 on my car on your car and
your at your car five minutes how much
um five hundred ninety dollars a month
oh my god okay and how much do you own
his car we paid that off what's it worth
um it's all I probably worth twenty
thousand only okay and so you're driving
sixty thousand dollars worth of cars you
make a hundred thousand dollars a year I
think I can help you on while you're
broke okay you're sitting in your
driveway yeah true yeah so um what if
you sold your car okay and then you sell
your car and then use what as you drive
a piece of crap the beater car yeah
matter of fact you could sell both cars
and buy a tenth to ten thousand dollar
cars which is far from a beater okay and
you'd have no car payments and that
would free up six hundred dollars a
month and then you could pay your family
what you owe them okay you're not going
to do that are you know I want to face
car we have four kids I want to save
cars I think ten thousand dollar cars
are safe no because it's going to have
issues and next
no you're at the shop every couple
months and then you're up to $10,000 in
shop bills
yeah Wriston you have no freaking idea
what you're talking about that was the
dumbest statement I've heard this week
that's absolutely ridiculous a $10,000
car is going to run up ten thousand
dollar bills and it's not safe to take
your children in seriously darling I
mean you said that out loud that's
that's just ridiculous
now I don't want you to drive a ten
thousand dollar car for the rest of your
life but if you suffered and I say that
sarcastically by driving a ten thousand
dollar car for a period of time you
could clean up your debts okay but
you're not going to do it well you know
if we need to do it we would yeah well
it says on my screen when you were
talking to Kelly my my phone screener it
says considering bankruptcy well no I
guess it was one of my questions is that
something we do or do we get you know do
we just kind of for credit cards we file
bankruptcy do we you definitely cut up
your credit cards and you definitely get
on a written budget and you definitely
sell your car and you clean up your mess
you guys have got to quit buying stuff
you can't afford right you're broke and
it's no fun honey I mean I'm poking fun
at you a little bit but it's no fun your
life's no fun you're stressed oh oh with
it yeah yeah and it's it's it's not
there's not peace in your marriage and
really all these things that you thought
we're going to bring you blessings
weren't it's it's stealing your life
away from you and and you know I want
you to have your life back but I will
tell you there's only one way I know to
get it back and that is to stop doing
the things that put you into the mess in
the first place and it's real simple you
and I did it too by the way so I'm not
just picking on you but you've bought
things you couldn't afford that you did
no money for and and now there's no
money and and you're sitting around
looking at your beautiful children going
you know we live in Atlanta Georgia we
make $100,000 a year and we feel
completely like poor people right and
it's stressed and your husband feels
like a rat in a wheel he feels like no
matter how hard he runs he can't seem to
get a traction well it's frustrating for
him you know this is the number one
cause of marriage discord
fights in marriage and even in divorce
right is the stress on this and and all
for a stupid car now by the way you can
have a nice car but you're going to have
to work your way around to getting the
mess cleaned up so you can save up and
pay for in cash a nice car okay because
if he called me up and owned two to
twenty thousand dollar cars that were
both paid for and you had no debt I
wouldn't be saying sell your car okay
but you said how do i I can't pay my
relatives that I owe money to and that's
so shame inducing isn't it oh it's the
worst feeling ever it's like my
Thanksgiving dinner doesn't taste good
alright it's hard to hang out with them
wait you know the Bible says the Bible
says the borrower is slave to the lender
and you know my wife's dad is one of the
nicest kindest men I have ever met in my
entire life and when we went broke 25
years ago and lost everything he loaned
us a little money and he never said an
unkind word but it changed the way I
felt when I stood in his presence
absolutely
even though and that wasn't on him it
was just it's just the enactment of a
principle well you feel trapped and
slaves feel trapped and so I think I
don't think that all those negative
things we've been talking about for the
last minute and a half or two minutes
are worth that car you're driving okay
and I would make that trade and I'm
trying to talk you into it for your own
good it doesn't matter to me but I'm
please know that you can have a ten
thousand dollar car that's safe enough
to drive children around in believe me
and and you can have a ten thousand
dollar car too that is reliable they all
break down new $100,000 cars fifty
thousand dollar cars ten thousand dollar
cars they all break down ten year old
cars brand new cars they all have
problems sometimes but I'm not asking to
drive a thousand dollar car and in your
situation you don't have to to achieve
your goals but you do need to take a
step back to get to solid ground so you
can take some other steps forward thanks
for calling in
you